i usually sit for
an hour
if i'm gonna lecture i've been doing a
lot of q and a's and that's a little
easier but if i'm gonna lecture i have
to sit for an hour and then i think okay
what question am i trying to investigate
i have to have that that's the point
what mystery am i trying to
unravel it's usually associated with one
of the rules in my book because
technically it's a book tour but each of
those rules is an investigation into an
ethic
and each of them points to a deeper sort
of mystery in some sense and
there's no end to the amount it can be
explored
and so i have the question
the question might be something like uh
put your
put your house in perfect order before
you criticize the world okay
what does that mean exactly put what
does house mean
what does put
what does put mean that active verb what
does perfect and order mean why before
you criticize the world what does it
mean to criticize what does it mean to
criticize the world how can you do that
properly or improperly so i start to
think about how to decompose the
question and you start to think which of
these decompositions are important to
really dig into yeah well then they'll
strike me it's like okay there's
something there that that i've been
maybe noodling around on that i would
like to investigate further then i think
okay how can i approach this problem i
think well i have this story that i know
i have this story and i have this story
but i haven't juxtaposed them before and
there's going to be some interesting
interaction in the juxtaposition so i
have the question and i kind of have a
framework of interpretation and then i
have some potential narrative places i
can go and then i think okay i can go
juggle that and see what happens
and so then what i want to do is
concentrate on that process while
attending to the audience to make sure
that the words are landing
and then see if i can delve into it
deeply enough so that a narrative
emerges spontaneously
with an ending now i'm sure you've
experienced this in podcasts right
maybe i'm wrong but my experience has
been if i fall into the conversation
and we know about the time frame
there'll be a natural narrative arc
and then so you'll kind of know when the
midpoint is and you'll kind of see when
you're reaching a conclusion and then if
you really pay attention you can see
that's a good place to stop
it's kind of you come to a point
and
you have to be alert and patient to see
that
and you have to be willing to be
satisfied with where you've got to but
if you do that and then it's like a
comedian making the
punch line work it's like
i've got all these balls in the air
and they're going somewhere
and this is
how they come together and people love
that right they say oh this and this
this and this
whack
together
and that's an insight and it is very
much like a punchline well that's
interesting because your mind actually
some i'm a fan of your podcast too and
you are always driving towards that i
would say
for me in in a podcast conversation
there's often a kind of
uh alice in wonderland type of
exploration
down the rabbit hole man and then you
just a new thing pops up and the more
absurd the wilder the better yeah
conversations with elon are like this
yeah it's like actually the more you
drive towards an arc the more
uncomfortable you start to get
in a fun absurd conversation because oh
i i'm now one of the normies no i don't
want that i want to be i want i want the
rabbit i want the crazy
because it makes it more uh
fun but somehow
throughout it there is
wisdom you try to grasp at well such
that there is a thread well that's the
thing man you're following the thread eh
yeah the threads
the thread well that's right that's what
we're trying to do that thread
that thread is the proper balance
between structure and spontaneity and it
manifests itself as the instinctive
meaning and that's the logos in the
dialogues and it really is the logos and
god only knows what that means
you know i mean the biblical claim is
that logos is the fundamental principle
of reality
and i think that's true
i actually think that's true
because i think that that meaning that
guides you well here's a way of thinking
but i've been writing about this
recently
what's real
matter it's like okay that's one answer
what's real
what matters is real
because that's how you act
okay so that's different than matter
it's like okay
what's the most real of what matters
how about pain
why is it the most real
try arguing it away
good luck
so pain is the fundamental reality all
right
well that's rough
doesn't that lead to nihilism and
hopelessness
yeah doesn't it lead to a philosophy
that's antithetical towards being the
most fundamental reality is pain
yes
is there anything more fundamental than
pain
love
really
if you're in pain
love and truth
that's what you got
and you know
if they're more powerful than pain
maybe they're the most real things
when you think about reality what is
real that is the most real thing
well it's a tough one right because you
have to
because if you're a scientist a
materialist think well
the matter is the most real it's like
well you don't know what the matter is
yeah and so and then when push comes to
shove and it will
you'll find out what's most real yeah
i i feel like this is uh
missing
physical reality is is missing some of
the things
so of course pain has a biological
component and all those kinds of things
but it it's missing something deep about
the human condition that
at least the modern science is not able
to
uh describe but it is reaching towards
that yeah it is the reason
one way to describe it as you're
describing is the reason it's reaching
it is because underneath of science is
this assumption that
there's a deep
logos
thing to this whole thing we're trying
to do
well you know there's two traditions
right in some sense there's two logos
traditions
there's the
the greek
rational
enlightenment tradition that's a logos
tradition and it insists that there's a
logos in nature and that science is the
way to approach it and then there's the
judeo-christian logos which is more
embodied and more spiritual and i would
say the west is actually an attempt to
unite those two
and it's the proper attempt to unite
those two
because they need to be united
and i see the union coming in near terms
you know i talk to friends to wall for
example about the animating principle of
chimpanzee sovereignty
and that's pretty close biologically is
it power
because that's the claim even from the
biologists often the most dominant chimp
has the best reproductive success
it's like
oh yeah
dominant eh you mean using compulsion
okay let's look
are the chimps who use compulsion
the most successful
and the answer is
sporadically and rarely
and for short well that's sporadically
for short periods of time why
because they meet an unpleasant end
the subordinates over whom they exercise
arbitrary control
wait for a weak moment and then tear
them into shreds
right
every dictator's terror
and for good reason and dewall has
showed that the alpha chimps the males
who do have preferential mating access
often
are often
and reliably
the best peacemakers and the most
reciprocal
and so even among chimps the principle
of sovereignty is something like
iterative iterated
reciprocity
and that's a way better principle than
power
and it's something like i've been
thinking what's the antithesis of the
spirit of power
i think it's the spirit of play
and you know you i don't know what you
think about that but when you have a
good podcast conversation you already
described it in some sense as play it's
like there's a structure right because
it's an ordered conversation but you
want there to be play in the system and
if you get that right then it's really
engaging and then it seems to have its
own
narrative arc i'm not trying to impose
that even though that's another thing i
don't do i didn't come to this
conversation
at all thinking here's what i want out
of a conversation with lex friedman like
instrumentally i thought
i'll go talk to lex why
i like his podcasts
he's doing something right i don't know
what it is he asks interesting questions
i'll go have a conversation with him
where's it going to go
wherever it goes
embracing the spirit of play
so what you have this
when you're lecturing
you're going in front of the crowd yeah
you thought of a question yeah
you get on the stage first of all are
you nervous at all
i'm very nervous when i'm sitting down
thinking through the structure
initially which is why my wife and i
have been doing q and a's and that's
easier on me yeah it's the uh
it's the the way comedians are nervous
like uh joe rogan just did his special
so this weekend and so he now has to sit
nervously like a comedian does which is
like
i have no material now
right i have to start from scratch when
i was doing the lectures constantly
instead of the q and a's
yes basically what i was doing was
writing a whole book chapter every night
and you know now that's a bit of an
exaggeration because i would return to
themes that i had developed but it's not
really an exaggeration because i didn't
ever
just
go over rote material ever
so it was it's very demanding and that
part's nerve-wracking because i sit down
it's an hour before the show and i think
can i pull can i do this
and you know the answer is well you did
it
a thousand times
but that's not this time yeah it's like
can i come up with a question can i
think through the structure can i pull
off the
spontaneous
narrative can i pull it together and the
answer is i don't know
and so then i get it together in my mind
i think and that's hard it takes effort
and it's nerve-wracking
okay i got it but then there's the
moment you go out on stage and you think
well i know i had it but can i do it no
notes
and then the question is well you're
gonna find out well you do it
and so then i go out on stage
and i don't talk to the audience
i talk to one person at a time
and you can talk to one person you know
because you know how to do that so i
talk to a person and not it's too long
because i don't want to make them too
nervous and then someone else and
someone else and then i'm in contact
with the audience and then i can tell
if the words are landing and i listen
it's like are they rustling around
are they dead quiet because they want
dead quiet you're so i see that's what
focus sounds like they catch you you're
in it together then you bet well and i
also here's a good rule if you're
learning to speak publicly i never say a
word
till everyone is 100 percent quiet
and that's it's a great way to start a
talk because
you're set in the frame and if the frame
is we'll all talk while you're talking
the message is
well you can talk
this is a place where everybody can talk
it's like no it's not
this is a place where people paid to
hear me talk
so i'm not going to talk till everyone's
listening
and so then you get that stillness
and then you just wait because that
stillness turns into an expectation and
then it comes turns into a kind of
nervous expectations like what the hell
is he doing it's not manipulative it's a
sense of timing it's like just when
that's right you think okay now it's
time to start well that nerve the
interesting thing about that nervous
expectation is from an audience
perspective we're in it together
yeah i mean there is into that silence
there's a togetherness to it of course
it's the union of everyone's attention
yeah yeah and that's
and that's a great thing i mean you love
that at a concert when everyone it's not
silence then but when everyone's
attention is unified and everyone's
moving in unison it's like we're all
worshiping the same thing
right is when that would be the point of
the conversation the point of the
lecture and the worship is the direction
of attention towards it and it's uni
it's communion because everyone's doing
it at the same time
and so i mean there's not much
difference between lecture theater and
the church in that regard right it's the
same fundamental layout and structure
and they're very integrally associated
with one another one really grew out of
the other the lecture theater grew out
of the church so it's it's perfectly
reasonable to be thinking about it in
those terms
you